this is
um my best friend Amanda
in her 40s Lorraine was diagnosed with
multiple myeloma a type of blood cancer
she's been living with the illness for
nearly a decade she will live with it
for the rest of her life
it's not curable it's never curable
because it's part of my bone marrow it's
part of my blood it's it's just not
something removed and then it's been in
the last year or so that the levels have
started to go up again which means that
the treatment I was having most recently
is no longer effective like most people
regardless of what cancer you've got
cancer is so
uh sneaky shall we say that it
recognizes treatments and it and it can
just stop working so I'm now waiting to
try a different type of treatment
thousands of people will share similar
experiences and that's only expected to
increase analysis by cancer research UK
suggests that by 2040 the number of
people diagnosed with cancer Will Rise
by a third this means cases per year are
expected to increase from around 384
000 to more than half a million
particularly for those over the age of
70. the charity says that action needs
to be taken now the less we increase
Workforce and access to Diagnostics
screening and really push early
detection within the NHS and ramp out
these rapid diagnostic Centers and
improve our health of the nation through
other ways such as restricting junk food
advertising
um trying to do our best to cut smoking
rates I think the future is deeply
worrying in response to this a
government spokesperson said we are
laser focused on fighting cancer on all
fronts prevention diagnosis treatment
research and funding so we can deliver
the best possible outcomes for patients
for Lorraine and so many others it's
essential that this commitment
materializes into better treatment and
better diagnosis Aisha zahid Sky News